une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce convaincre nos invités
avec moi dôme plante quel plaisir quelle
rencontre incroyable aujourd'hui on
s'est entretenu avec fady dagger qui est
le chef de police de Longueuil de
Montréal anciennement chef de police de
Longueuil qui travaille aussi longtemps
à Montréal comme policier
quelqu'un qui ne peut vraiment une
vision différente de la police quelqu'un
qui veut réellement
révolutionner la police tout en gardant
ce qui avait de bon mais en changeant ce
qui doit changer en ayant d'approche
plus de prévention plus de communautés
plus de
plus proche des gens de l'approche de
proximité c'est vraiment inspirant de
l'entendre parler c'est quelqu'un que
qu'on sent vraiment
honnête et transparent dans sa dans son
désir de servir là la population les
citoyens c'est quelqu'un que moi j'ai
réellement envie de faire confiance
comme ça de la police je pense que j'ai
l'impression que écouter ce podcast là
si vous êtes quelqu'un qui a des
peut-être une
image négative des préjugés juste des ou
que des expériences négatives avec la
police je penserai allemand que
qu'entendre cette personne là
peut aider à changer votre vision que
vous avez du corps policier puis de son
rôle puis aussi de comment qui va
comment que tu transforme en fait
maintenant en 2023 sous sa gouverne tout
à fait c'est vraiment un de mes podcasts
préférés qu'on a fait depuis longtemps
là vous allez voir c'est une
conversation qui qui coule vraiment
facilement parce que Fadi est comme il y
a vraiment été à l'aise en fait en
communication ça paraît puis je crois
aussi que c'est une des comme ils nous
explique c'est une des vocations qu'il
s'est lui-même donné d'aller dans les
médias pour essayer de refaire le pont
puis c'est c'est fascinant honnêtement
c'était une super conversation j'étais
encore on vient tout juste de terminer
le podcast encore sur le choc de comment
c'était le fun comment c'était
intéressant donc on espère que vous
allez aimer la conversation autant qu'on
a aimé la voir donc bon podcast bonne
écoute le podcast aujourd'hui est
présenté par mendescape nos amis de chez
manscape nos amis de toujours qui nous
supportent et que et qu'on supporte et
qu'on aime réellement les produits on
les utilise moi j'utilise très souvent
le
trust package qu'ici avec le petit
rasoir le crop Sherer qui est un petit
rasoir vraiment vraiment fin et qui va
dans tous les recoins les plus les plus
difficiles d'accès
et âgée la plus tard
bien sous la peau qui rase avec douceur
mais avec précision
ça vient avec le kit avec le gel à
rasage et un petit texte foliant pour
avoir une peau bien douce et pour éviter
tout poil incarné et autres choses
désagréable alors on a un code promo pH
juste avant le code promo je veux juste
faire un charlotte aux gars qui a déjà
écrit dans les commentaires sur Youtube
que la seule raison pour parler de
m'insky parce qu'on était payé pour le
faire mais oui c'est une publicité en
fait mais on utilise réellement les
produits mainscape mais vous savez c'est
une publicité qu'on fait c'est normal
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne on a un
code promo pour vous et le code sans
filtre pour 20% de rabais et la
livraison gratuite et si vous êtes pour
commander men'scape pour vous ou pour un
être cher utiliser notre code et
assurez-vous de bien l'utiliser comme ça
ça leur indique que nous on vous envoie
donc ça n'encourage le sans ça
l'encourage vous encourage tout le monde
mais tout le monde est content donc code
promo sans filtre 20% rabais et le
shipping gratuit merci menskate ça
serait quand même qu'on parle pendant
une minute et demi de man's Skype à
chaque début de podcasts
à chaque à chaque jour on tente le monde
mais avec une nouvelle compagnie qui
nous paye pas c'est que on fait une
minute de 1h30 de publicité en début
mais pas une publicité juste parce que
on traite on veut que le monde aille une
minute 30 de messages ça fait même
podcast bref mon podcast
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça roule excellent merci beaucoup d'être
là merci à vous on veut juste continuer
dans le fond sur ce qu'on disait on
parlait du lien de confiance entre le
service de police ce que ce que tu
représentes et la population puis
comment c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
construire sur des années c'est comment
est-ce qu'on s'y prend tu es en pause
depuis quelques mois maintenant comment
est-ce qu'on s'y prend c'est quoi le
plan à long terme mais l'avantage
l'avantage par contre que GPH c'est que
j'ai fait de 25 ans à Montréal donc
c'est 25 années j'ai vraiment passé du
temps et des années à partir des points
avec des partenaires puis dès mon
discours du 19 janvier j'ai mentionné
que le SPVM doit et sera au service de
toutes les populations c'était moins
important parce que tu peux pas comme
policier choisi avec qui tu veux faire
affaire donc comment le bâtir faut
surtout pas le bâtir en temps de crise
il faut surtout le bâtir en temps de
paix puis ce qui marche que j'ai appris
quand j'étais à Saint Michel comme
commandant c'est que avec les grades que
je suis épaules ça me donne les
avantages d'avoir des liens privilégiés
avec divers services d'avil l'école
bleue les tout ce qui est l'urbanisme
les parcs les émondage d'arbre
d'éclairage et quand les gens dans le
quartier me disent hey notre quartier
des délabrée mon quartier le pacte on ne
peut pas y aller on a peur
mais c'est rien à voir avec la police
mais j'appelle le chef des parcs
j'appelle le chef des émondages peux-tu
me rendre un service et mon mot de passe
et là le partenaire ou le citoyen cornet
ça fait 5 ans qu'on attend puis tout à
coup il veut pas que change là il te
regarde pas comme le chef de police mais
comme fady comme quelqu'un qui les avait
dit puis moi j'ai rien demandé je
demanderai en retour puis tranquillement
pas vite tu bâtis des ponts et ça prend
des années des années bâtir ces points
là parce que et si un jour un événement
malheureux arrive
mais au moins tu as été là avec eux dans
les bons dans les bons temps et on verra
comment la population va réagir
ouais effectivement puis mais c'est une
façon de le voir que j'avais pas
vraiment pensé parce que effectivement
que les gens se tournent vers la police
pour pratiquement tout même ça le pas
nécessairement c'est pas nécessairement
leur cours mais c'est vrai que si il
semble que
cette main tendue là est prise ça peut
définitivement les aider à sentir
appuyer en fait mais c'est parce que ça
dépend comment les gens décrivent leur
service de police moi c'est une notion
de véhicules de police écrit protéger et
servir il s'agit pas de
protéger
son cul puis servir son boss
il s'agit il s'agit vraiment de
voiture
c'est vraiment pas ça dans le sens
qu'elle a qui font mais je trouve ça
vraiment c'est protéger service c'est
quoi servir un gars te parle ou une
communauté de disque leur parc n'est pas
n'est pas on peut pas y aller mais si tu
as des réseaux comme un directeur un
réseau de service de la ville que tu
peux influencer pour aider des gens mais
c'est ça ton rôle aussi servir tout le
monde
moi je vous remercie d'avoir accepté de
venir ici mais c'est quoi la réflexion
on te voit pardon on te vouvoie mais on
te tutoie mais on vous voit le titre ok
d'accord mais c'est bon ça je joue un
rôle je suis pas le directeur j'agis
comme directeur fady et quelqu'un
d'autre qu'un directeur aujourd'hui on
parle à Fadi où on parle de dire comme
tu veux
je voulais quand tu veux mais on te voit
on te voit plus dans les médias en fait
que que moi j'ai pas le souvenir en fait
d'un directeur de police
qu'on voit dans les médias tant que ça
en fait la personne qui qui paye le
poste avant avant toi je pourrais pour
être franche je me suis impossible puis
je me suis pas là qui s'est passé
c'est quoi cette c'est quoi la réflexion
derrière le fait de vouloir être plus
être visible puis
j'imagine que c'est c'est une très très
bonne question parce que il y en a
c'est une très très bonne question parce
qu'il y en a qui ils pensent que je suis
Kodak on a directeur Kodak et
franchement ce qui me connaissent savent
très bien ce qu'on m'a stratégie puis je
l'ai dit récemment dans un média avec
dans les médias avec Marie
j'oublie son nom la journaliste très
très bon journaliste elle me dit mais
pourquoi vous êtes autant dans les
médias mais je dis madame je me sers de
vous
il faut que j'utilise les médias pour
passer mes messages j'ai pas d'autres
choix media sociaux médias traditionnels
médias écrit il faut absolument que je
sois extrêmement présent dans les médias
pour passer mes messages de vers où le
SPB vient veut aller ce que notre vision
est démystifier aussi le métier policier
parce que franchement tout à l'heure PHG
la police on dirait rendu un fourre-tout
appelle la police pour n'importe quoi
pour n'importe quel moment et puis on
s'attend ce que des magiciens les agents
réagissent arrivent chez l'événement
puis règle tout santé mentale détresse
humaine chicken de voisinage j'ai vu un
chat dans l'arbre
la police peut pas faire ça ne doit pas
faire ça fait que le média c'est
vraiment vraiment pour moi extrêmement
important qui qu'on puisse quand je dis
utiliser c'est pas péjoratif c'est
plutôt passé mon message passer mon
message à toutes les populations parce
qu'on est tellement pas connu moi j'ai
toujours dit souvent et envie de
solitude la solitude police la société
population puis ça se mélange pas
souvent la seule moment que tu te
mélange avec nous c'est dans des
événements malheureux ou un billet de
contravention ou une intervention ou
tant que tu ne vois toujours de manière
répressive mais la police est tellement
plus donc dans le média tu as vu
récemment j'ai passé pour immersion j'ai
passé mes policiers pour immersion on a
fait le projet réseau à Longueuil mais
quand la population c'est via le média
qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais voyons donc ça
change la perception la perception de la
police et moi ce que je trouve très très
intéressant c'est policiers surtout
connecte avec la population différemment
lorsqu'il passe dans les médias il se
voit il dit ok on est apprécie
finalement vous n'êtes pas une gang à
part la police non les gens vous
apprécient mais vous sortez de votre
véhicule mais si vos fenêtres allez-y
bonjour parler aux gens uniformes ça
bloque l'uniforme ça bloque souvent par
des minorités visibles mais une police
moi je suis minorité visible libanaise
j'ai une double minorité mon uniforme tu
me vois 10 km et des centaines de mètres
donc c'est vraiment démystifié puis
j'utilise les médias exprès pour ça
parce que de toute façon les médias vont
nous utiliser à leur manière aussi donc
on essaie de faire un contrepoids c'est
une manière justement de rétablir ce
lien qu'on compte qu'on disait parce que
si je me mets dans la peau d'un jeune
puis si je vous vois dans les médias je
me dis ah ben peut-être que c'est vous
n'êtes pas le
l'image qu'on peut se faire
confiance
on peut on rétablisse ça donc c'est de
la prévention finalement vous avez la
prévention préparation du terrain se
rapprocher se rapprocher puis l'avantage
c'est que oui OK je suis la personne qui
prend la parole en avant mais souvent
dans de Longueuil quand j'étais
directeur pas en a développé des
policiers des policiers très bons à
échanger avec les médias et c'est eux
qui ont pris le relais ils sont vraiment
exceptionnels donc il a fait 10 qui
commence mais tranquillement pas vite
les autres prennent le relais puis là
c'est à coup la population directe la
police de Longueuil et découle la plus
de Montréal est différente elle est cool
c'est ça il faut il faut créer le base
avec la avec la population les
populations dire parce que franchement
au quotidien c'est plutôt négatif c'est
plutôt très
ingrat comme Job ouais vraiment tu vas
pas sur les appels personne à peine de
faire pour dire et on aimerait se voir
mais c'est vrai ce que tu disais par
rapport à la perception de la population
puis nos interactions avec les policiers
sont tout le temps négatives c'est tout
le temps un biais de contravention c'est
tout le temps c'est l'espèce de
sentiment quand tu es sur l'autoroute
puis que
un policier allume ses phares écoutez
d'avoir les jambesciées puis l'espèce de
sentiment même si tu sais que tu as pas
rouler trop vite tu sais que tu n'as
rien fait tu as quand même l'espèce
la police est là alors que on n'est pas
dehors la loi on est on est des gens
très corrects mais mais c'est quoi les
les pistes à part justement c'est
médiatique de pouvoir
pas redorer l'image mais de pouvoir
changer la personne changer la
perception des gens entier dans dans la
dans la dans la vraie vie mais tu vois
le je donne l'exemple du projet
immersion et merci de septembre
pendant quatre semaines toutes les
recrues qui vont entrer au SPVM vont
aller vivre dans quatre semaines dans la
communauté donc déjà le policier qui
arrive je peux modifier bougamu qui
habite pas Montréal qui semble
travailler 30 à Montréal mais je vais
l'envoyer à côté de neige je vais
l'envoyer Auchan Laga maison neuve je
vais l'envoyer chez je vais envoyer chez
un autiste chez les femmes violentées au
chaînon pour qu'il aille voir c'est quoi
le Montréal puis qu'il aille voir aussi
des quartiers où tout va bien où tout va
très très bien puis donc une de mes je
vous coupe
la journée la soirée moi dans mon
immersion j'ai dormi là j'ai fait matin
midi soir et la nuit eux à cause du côté
syndical côté de la convention
collective ils vont faire jour et soir
donc allez l'épicerie avec une famille
exemple une famille qui est dans le
jeune garçon est autiste ils vont à
l'école d'autiste avec le jeune
s'asseoir avec lui voir sa réalité au
quotidien souper dans la même famille
aller à l'épicerie avec le jeune et sa
maman ou son papa et des parents elle
est dans l'épicerie et voir comment ça
se passe avec le jeune aller à la maison
souper avec eux cuisiner avec eux donc
vive le quotidien de la famille même
chose les itinérants moi je suis allé
servir des repas je suis allé même
m'asseoir et que j'allais dormir là eux
ils vont pas dormir mais vive le
quotidien la réalité et une fois que tu
l'as vécu mais jeune homme jeune fille
quand tu vas porter uniforme là
souviens-toi souviens-toi souviens-toi
de ce que tu as vu et ça ça crée de la
proximité ça ça crée le lien de
confiance avec la avec les participants
il m'a donné un exemple que j'avais vécu
pas moi mais mes policiers
j'avais envoyé des policiers dans une
famille congolaise et la femme
congolaise dans la dans l'appartement
reçoit les deux policiers les policière
puis la police dire nous notre carrière
on vit d'en faire c'est pas facile être
policier
tu veux que je te parle d'enfer
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
une réfugiée du Congo elle ouvre la
porte de la chambre qui avait 7 lits
cette violence
et là la police elle regarde et tu es
sérieuse
cet enfant n'ont voulu
et là le regarde dans la poésie donc les
petits bobos de la policière versus
qu'elle a vu de sa citoyenne elle a dit
ok maintenant je comprends ça c'est la
marque à vie waouh ça m'a marqué la vie
donc c'est un peu de ces exemplaires de
génotiste qui rentre au avec sa maman en
faisant 12 ans et les policiers sont à
côté mais en civil immersion sans civile
personne ne sait que tu es là à part les
personnes qui tu es puis le jeune a au
mois de novembre que ce que 2019 je
pense il y a
comment dire il y a plein de décorations
et c'est des organisé la mère essaie de
contrôler son garçon
impossible la population autour dans le
couscous l'insulte et ton enfant là ton
sentimentale ton malade mental contre le
tu sais pas l'éduquer les policiers
étaient là et là les policiers voulaient
intervenir
interviens pas tu regardes tu observes
puis il faut qu'ils ont marqué dans la
voiture et la contrôlé finalement son
enfant mais elle a reçu des insultes il
faut qu'ils ont embarqués dans la
voiture les priscillités Verts et rien à
maman dit Madame ça vous arrive souvent
maintenant je comprends mieux si je m'en
fiche un appel d'un jeune autiste je
connais les codes j'ai quand même mieux
intervenir c'est un peu tout ça ça c'est
le projet immersion mais ce projet là
juste pour pour finir là-dessus sur sur
ce dossier là ce projet-là il est en
place maintenant
il commence en septembre 28 et ça va
être
obligatoire pour tous les recrues tous
les recrues c'est combien de temps
quatre semaines quatre semaines jour et
soir jour et soir avec les mêmes
familles ou avec plusieurs non non
justement ça c'est un grand enjeu à
Longueuil on avait 70 familles et
milieux communautaires
là Montréal c'est une autre histoire le
faisait à chaque deux fois par année
parce qu'on recrutait deux fois par
année ici on recrute à chaque six
semaines donc ça nous prend du monde ça
nous prend 1000 à 2000 partenaires
familles à nous recevoir on peut pas
faire ça avec la même famille tout le
temps ils vont s'épuiser à nous recevoir
donc retrouve plusieurs familles à faire
le relais c'est vraiment titanesque
comme projet c'est une première au monde
c'est pas un autre corps de police qui
fait ça personne ne fait ça quatre
semaines dans la communauté puis à la
même des moments de répit pour les
pour les recrues parce que
psychologiquement et mentalement c'est
difficile moi j'ai vécu cinq jours et
dormi dans les refuges après trois nuits
je t'ai plus capable il me voyant donc
je me sentais pas bien psychologiquement
je vois gris je suis fatigué je suis
aigri je devenais très irritable en
trois jours imagine-toi une vie complet
il y a d'autres choses qu'on a on amène
on veut aussi revoir toutes les critères
de sélection des recrues donc recruter
des profils de policiers policières qui
sont plus au reflet de la population
donc avec des des compétences
intellectuelles oui mais des compétences
relationnelles émotionnelles être de
parler du monde débarquer on lui dit à
la personne qu'est-ce que tu fais ici
toi c'est parce que en disant cette
phrase là tu es en train de l'exclure
déjà du quartier plutôt tu lui dis à la
personne bonsoir Monsieur qu'est-ce que
vous faites dans notre coin qu'est-ce
qu'on peut tout vous aider comment on
peut vous aider vous allez vers vous
différemment c'est tout une approche
qu'on veut revoir au niveau de
l'approche plus relationnelle que
technique puis on veut plus
nécessairement on veut continuer à
évaluer le nombre de billets de données
des contraventions ou des arrestations
mais c'est pas du tout un aspect qui va
être prioritaire c'est beaucoup plus
comment tu vas chez les appels comment
tu règles l'appel comment tu es avec la
population comment tu règles des
situations délicate t'arrives-tu à
sortir de là avec une certaine empathie
tout en restant dans ton cas de travail
mais en développant une année de
confiance ça c'est des bonnes
évaluations que ça viennent mais c'est
ça tout en restant c'est la ligne la
moins rester
les forces de l'ordre il faut que tu
restes il faut que tu restes les forces
de l'ordre parce que regarde
moi j'ai des policiers et des policiers
fait 33 ans chez policier c'est drôle il
y en a qui font des arrestations ils
font dans des billets et tout puis ils
le font toujours sans aucun problème il
y en a d'autres qui font des
arrestations ou dans des billets il y a
toujours des problèmes donc c'est une
question aussi souvent d'attitude c'est
pas tout le temps ça parce que parfois
la population est vraiment pas contente
qu'on les interpelle et ça peut
malheureusement c'est pas toujours la
faute des policiers c'est de part et
d'autre tout à fait mais si s'il y a des
des agents à qui ça se produit
systématiquement il y a un problème ça
veut dire que le problème n'est pas dans
la population de la population puis ça
vous j'imagine en tant que groupe en
tant que force policière vous êtes
capable de voir
comment est-ce qu'on comment est-ce
qu'on intervient au niveau de l'individu
l'individu on peut intervenir de manière
préventive le mode de le prendre de côté
puis dire rien ça fait six mois qui est
dans tel poste puis ça fait à peu près 5
6 fois tu utilises les armes
intermédiaires le peuple spoiler ou le
bâton il y en a qui l'utilisent jamais
quartier
comment ça va comment ça va
professionnellement puis comment ça va
personnellement passer un travail
extrêmement difficile est-ce qu'il y en
a des interventions comme ça tu sais
peut-être avec des des experts en santé
mentale utile de vraiment rencontrer les
officiers de là c'est je te dirai que
c'est pas quelque chose c'est pas un
instinct qu'on a c'est pas une
automatisme qu'on a c'est quelque chose
qu'on développe beaucoup plus au lieu
parce que les gens disent
telle politique ça peut être fadiste
hyper répressif hyper négatif ok il y a
deux choix soit je le ramasse en
discipline je vais être avec toi
pas sûr que ça donne grand chose ça peut
aider
soit je dis viens t'asseoir qu'est-ce
qui se passe et franchement péage la
plupart des fois le gars il ouvre comme
une canne de bine et là tout à coup tu
dis ok ok il y a des enjeux personnels
professionnels ça va pas bien vous qu'on
l'aide et moi je dis j'ai déjà dit à mes
gestionnaires et pas question qu'on
rentre à discipline en partant et
question de voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
une fois que tu t'enlèves tu te soutiens
tu l'amènes tu le fais cheminer puis le
gars ou les filles comprend mais on le
vient de sortir un problème le gars ou
les filles veut pas comprendre mais là
c'est notre histoire là à ce moment-là
au moins je me sentir moralement
éthiquement d'avoir essayé de prendre
soin de la personne et après ça
je comprends finalement c'est un peu la
même approche avec la population même de
l'organisation c'est
d'abord
la première fois je fais le lien
dans les manifs moi j'étais quand
j'étais à Montréal dans les manifs
étudiantes et des carrés rouges et tout
puis ça a amené un conflit énorme
dans le milieu policier à l'intérieur
même parce que beaucoup de policiers
on se souvient de la matricule de
certains agents qui ont fait paraître
toute la profession de façon moins
de certains agents mais tu sais tu sais
que cette période là il y a eu des
tensions énormes à l'interne parce que
les policiers policières étaient parents
leurs enfants
portaient
les hommes externes tu vois on
communique aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui va
entendre ça il va peut-être dire oh pas
vu ça de même c'est vrai on avait des
gens de très haut niveau au SPVM dans
leurs enfants étaient des carrés rouges
et qui devait souper de Noël même eux je
peux vous dire des souper de Noël c'est
pas évident donc eux ils étaient ils
travaillaient
comme professionnel a contrôlé la
manifestation et à la maison leurs
propres enfants leur disait papa ou
maman qu'est-ce que tu fais là donc tu
me dises comment c'est difficile
mentalement c'est extrêmement difficile
puis je me rappelle cette période là
c'est pour ça qu'on a déclaré que toutes
à part les manifestations on savait
qu'il y avait de la casse là
malheureusement ils étaient toutes des
manifestations de nuit mais si vous vous
souvenez le 22 du mois on avait en
moyenne 150
000 à 200 000 personnes qui marchaient
et on n'avait jamais
arrêter ces manifestations là on a dit
elle est illégale mais tolérer puis
rappelez-vous
le politique provincial nous avait
demandé d'appliquer la loi
je sais pas si 72 78 bon souviens plus
où ils nous empêché les rassemblements
donc on devait on a dit non on peut pas
faire on peut pas non seulement on peut
pas faire ça mais dites-moi par là on
n'est pas on n'est pas le bras d'un
gouvernement de quiconque on est un
politique si nous on sent que c'est une
manifestation raisonnable oui est
illégale parce que par la loi mais voilà
tolérer
je peux vous dire une chose je me suis
pas fatigué
est légal mais toléré
rappelez-vous des casseroles mais ça
c'était chouette c'était le fun mais on
a fait des erreurs je vous avoue et moi
je suis un des premiers que quand 2013 à
ce moment-là tu étais à Montréal j'étais
à Montréal puis j'étais à la fin des
manifestations ses responsables des
manifs de toutes les manifs de Montréal
et elle m'a donné on a fait des erreurs
puis on a été on a été poursuivi puis on
a perdu puis c'était correct c'est par
rapport à l'article P6 qui est le P6
le Pessis nous empêchait d'avoir des
rassemblements peu plus exactement des
détails du de l'article mais la fête des
arrestations de masse
480 personnes puis
ça a pas été la meilleure le meilleur
décision qu'on a pris puis là après ça
en 2014 je suis retourné dans les
universités et dans les cégep pour
rencontrer des personnes
j'ai reçu des soupes de ministres
pas là vous rentrez pas là mais c'est
important pour moi d'essayer de
rencontrer déjà avec des voyants on
s'excuse pour telle partie mais l'autre
partie c'est nécessaire
puis à la fin ça finissait par les gens
disent bon ben j'ai vu le gars au moins
devenu nous parler mais il faut on a pas
le choix puis à l'interne juste pour
parler encore de 2012 à l'interne est-ce
qu'il y avait des
comment dire des
divergences d'opinions sur
la façon avec laquelle c'était géré par
le corps policier tire au sens justement
les débordements c'est de matricule 7 28
pour la nommer est-ce que clairement
c'est pas tout le monde qui devait être
d'accord avec sa façon puis il devait
avoir une certaine tension entre les
gens qui étaient vraiment plus dans la
réponse l'idée de manifester pour ça qui
était un peu dans c'est honnêtement de
la haine qui était qui était transporté
par par cette image là tu sais puis
d'autres personnes qui devaient être
plus en mode comme qui ont leurs enfants
dans la qui comprennent la manette qui
comprennent l'importance pour
l'importance mais qui comprennent le
moment
est-ce qu'il y avait une tension à
l'interne à cause des réseaux
documentation mais oui si ministre
société la police là c'est une c'est un
quartier une diversité de diversités
[Musique]
les gens focus beaucoup sur cette de 8
c'est une chose et c'est cas particulier
c'est une situation particulière mais la
pression que vivait nos policiers c'est
ça franchement là je vais donner un
exemple maintenant à l'encontre
je descends sur le terrain sur les
chenille de piquetage une ligne de front
et mes policiers sont debout depuis deux
trois heures de temps devant une idée de
personnes puissions derrière et je le
répète la phrase
gâteau debout et je leur dis c'était 41
je leur dis retenu émotionnelle tenue
intellectuelle vous le répète retenez
émotionnel tenue intellectuel personne
ne tombe dans le piège retenez
émotionnel tenue intellectuelle personne
tombe dans le piège parce qu'en Europe
dans le mouvement juste avant juste
avant le mouvement étudiant il avait
occupé tout mouvement occupé à 99% puis
ils avaient réussi malheureusement en
Europe de créer des martyrs des
mouvements envoyés des jeunes et
finalement ça finissait par une soirée
fusillade ou quelqu'un qui mourait moi
je voulais éviter ça Montréal et par
contre
donner du gaz
et qui finit mal et là après ça tout le
monde légitimé de faire ce qu'ils
veulent
tout le monde ferme
les gens du pays des gens en face des
policiers ils avaient des cannes à pêche
avec des bains au bout
puis pendant des heures il prenait de
beigne et le swinguait vers la visière
juste avant la visière ah ouais mon
cochon mange mon cochon
écoute
bouge pas
des heures pas de 3 minutes là laisse le
faire
mais ça là c'est maintenant parlant à 30
degrés 40 degrés et tout uniforme puis
tu te fais faire ça cette
dynamique là moi toujours tellement
dépassé tu sais maintenant que tu vas en
manifester pour pour justement dans
cette situation là le gel des frais de
scolarité ou peu importe c'est quoi la
raison
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
certaines personnes pensent sentaient à
être en compétition ou en opposition
avec avec les forces de l'ordre c'est
pas ça le point on dirait mais je
comprends comme pas moi comment tu peux
en arriver en disant dans le fond l'idée
c'est juste de créer du trouble mais ça
dépend parce qu'il y avait une portion
qui était vraiment là pour les bonnes
raisons
s'exprimer au contraire moi je disais
souvent si si s'exprime pas là
on va voir un enjeu plus tard au
contraire que les gens ils leur donnent
le plus possible d'espace pour le faire
mais malheureusement c'est
l'infiltration de certains groupes plus
marginalisés qui eux sont pas du tout
[Musique]
quand ils sont pas du tout du tout là
pour les bonnes raisons eux ils ont tout
agenda qui n'ont rien à voir
cette idée-là me fait faire le saut
jusqu'à aujourd'hui puis hier en fait
hier avant hier ou est-ce que là il y a
comme des groupes facebook qui partagent
des
on se rencontre au Centre Eaton pour
faire de la case comme en France c'est
on a vu ça passer le puis là hier
c'était aux Galeries d'Anjou je pense
qu'il y avait comme une genre de
rencontre pour faire de la casse pour
aucune raison dans le fond là comment
est-ce que
vous prenez
action pour être sûr de gérer la
situation mais pas sur réagir sur un
genre de micro groupe qui au final
veulent juste faire sur réagir c'est
comment est-ce qu'on gère cette balance
là c'est sûr que nous on a le côté
renseignement criminel qui nous dit à
peu près qui est en train de préparer ça
et il y a plusieurs techniques
premièrement il y a des visibilité à
l'endroit donc
véhicules pour faire comprendre le
message si vous faites des conneries
je présente puis on bouge pas là pas
quand on rentre et on va fouiller
partout non non la présence policière
est là déjà là il y a un gros qui va
dire ça me tente plus
l'autre partie c'est quand tu sais
exactement qui
toi
on sait que tu prépares de quoi c'est
pas compliqué là 1 + 1 2 et de quoi qui
arrive là c'est donc on va regarder oups
donc préventif on n'attend pas que les
gens le fassent pour qu'on commence à
les poursuivre beaucoup beaucoup de
prévention beaucoup de liens avec
beaucoup de
démystification aussi avec les autres
parce qu'il y a il y a une violence
je pense que le média sociaux c'est
extrêmement intéressant et fascinant
parce que quand tu es en France
et tu es à Montréal c'est comme si ton
cousin est invité à deux pas de toi et
tu veux agir comme aux États-Unis qu'on
a eu Josh Floyd qu'on a eu Memphis
récemment tout à coup la communauté se
sent interpellée immédiatement dans son
quartier dans sa rue
mais moi je pensais beaucoup de l'aspect
de prévention et les leaders les leaders
de la communauté comme je te parlais
tantôt faire des liens avec des
partenaires pas en tant de crise mais
attend de paix exemple moi disons que tu
étais proche d'une communauté pendant 10
ans tu travailles avec eux sur toutes
sortes de choses positives puissantes la
violence montée dans leur quartier
fadier en petite parler ça brasse là
puis tout d'un coup tu peux intervenir
en proactif en amont avant
puis malheureusement j'ai vu ce que tu
dis elle est rendez vous et tout et
c'est un risque c'est un gros risque
parce que la tentation de vouloir se
défouler par contre et là ça a peut-être
théorique mais c'est important s'il y a
du monde qui veulent l'embarquer
là-dedans il y a deux choses et l'aspect
criminel mais à l'esprit des jeunes ou
des groupes de personnes qui sont pas
écoutés se sentent margériser qui se
sentent toujours opprimées qui se sont
toujours toujours toujours sous estimés
et on les écoute jamais c'est fascinant
tu regardes Trump comment ce président
là a été élu c'est pas la majorité
silencieuse qui n'a jamais été écouté
qu'elle s'est mis de côté
ça se peut même qu'il revienne encore
donc moi je dis au contraire les gens
qu'on peut vous pensez négliger au
contraire mais en avant qu'on peut en
avoir une discussion ayant une
conversation pour pas qu'ils se refoule
se marginalise et pète un événement
ça c'est très très très très important
on parle de France mais ça peut nous
arriver chez nous on a reçu ici j'oublie
son nom
radicalisation menant à la violence
[Musique]
un chercheur ou un praticien sur le
terrain chercheur
la diction c'était surtout comme comment
on fait pour justement
amener tout le monde dans une
conversation les familles ça passe par
les familles ça passe par les familles
ça passe par les le milieu l'église ou
la mosquée ou le pasteur ou le temple ça
passe par les oncles les cousins les
familles ça passe par beaucoup de liens
de comment encore une fois si j'ai des
liens dans une communauté pendant 10 ans
c'est certain que le jeune caca va en
parler il y a tel jeune
comportement quelqu'un va nous parler
puis c'est pas pour l'enquêter on la
vallée là c'est pas pour le faire de la
répression c'est plutôt exactement comme
même le mot policier
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce que
changer comportement puis en quelque
part si sans qu'il a l'écoute la tension
de la valorisation de l'estime à
quelqu'un qui veut me parler
peut-être tu es en train d'aller dans la
mauvaise gang Satan tu conseilles la
bonne gang puis ça je pense que les
familles l'esprit des villages moi je
parle beaucoup moi je vais de la Côte
d'Ivoire d'Afrique et du Liban
l'esprit du village et du qu'un enfant
c'est pas tes parents qui éduquent c'est
pas juste tes parents le conjugue
l'enseignant le prof de piano il y a
plein de monde autour de toi eux là
s'ils ont une bonne influence sur toi
c'est avec eux faut travailler pour te
ramener
je reviens sur
la réalité d'aujourd'hui justement des
réseaux sociaux tu disais tout
se rapproche en fait ce qui se passe en
France influence qui puisse passer ce
qui se passe autour des États-Unis
la tragédie de Etats-Unis puis c'est
comme ça lui a un effet immédiat sur ici
la manière dont on perçoit la police
puis quand au final je veux dire c'est
pas le même cas policier réalité qu'on
le mette vous travaillez de longue
haleine pour tisser des liens qu'il
communauté puis une trajet une tragédie
qui arrive dans un autre pays
peut avoir une une façon dont vous êtes
perçu dans les policiers partout dans le
monde notamment sont perçus c'est quand
même
dans les corps policier quand on se dit
entre nous l'impact de l'uniforme et un
uniforme un uniforme que tu prends en
Europe aux États-Unis au quelque part et
étudier fait le lien avec Montréal à
c'est le même policier à le mettre en 2
minutes juste la militarisation aux
États-Unis pire non seulement ils sont
très militarisés en plus c'est 80 il y a
pas de partout là mais c'est parfois
souvent dans plusieurs états 90 heures
de formation
écoute 90 heures là c'est deux semaines
nous c'est trois ans et demi
trois ans ouais presque 3 ans et demi à
la fin 3 3 ans techniques policières 15
semaines de Nicolette de l'Académie des
collègues que tu sors de là là
tu es vraiment vraiment dérivé entraîné
à faire vraiment attention puis dans un
milieu beaucoup plus social libéral et
tout là tu me compare à des policier
américain pire ces deux policiers qui
étaient en cause ça faisait 16 et 18
fois qu'il y avait des événements des
déontologies disciplinaires en lien avec
l'agressivité donc il y a personne qui a
réagi pendant 16 à 18 fois donc c'est un
paquet de choses mais oui c'est
décourageant parce que du coup
médias sociaux
arrivent à Montréal certaines personnes
prennent ça puisse révolte sa prise
Montréal
mettez la peau du policier qui regarde
ça dit mais moi
c'est pour ça que moi à ce moment là
j'étais en orgueil tout de suite tout de
suite je suis sorti et j'ai dit ça
c'était meurtre
c'est inacceptable puis nous à Longueuil
exemple on travaille pas de même puis
quand même un fils est arrivé j'étais à
Montréal quand mes fils arrivé sorti
immédiatement et j'ai dit je condense
cet événement là car nos policiers ne
travaillent pas comme ça pour que au
moins tout le monde dise ok peut-être le
chef il dit que ça je sais pas ça me
fait plaisir je dis ça parce qu'on
travaille pas de même je sais pas si
vous avez vu les vidéos de mes fesses
c'est 4 5 policiers sur un jeune mais à
coup de poing fermé il attrape les bras
puis il le fera plus visage elle coupe
la famille bidule sur place là exécution
c'est c'est tellement des
je suis comme j'ai perdu ce que j'allais
dire parce que c'est horrible
honnêtement ça va comme ça mais le
avec des amis puis des amis d'amises des
connaissances puis durant la covid où
est-ce que les parcs qui étaient rendus
à l'endroit où aller ouais c'est ça pile
je pense que la règle à ce moment-là
c'était à 11h fallait quitter le parti
donc là il est 11h la loi veut qu'on
quitte le parc puis là les policiers
arrivent
vous devez partir c'est de façon super
Pacifique
puis là je me souviens une personne une
fille avec un été qu'on connaissait pas
vraiment mais qui a ami d'amis tu disais
genre
on est là
on a quand même fait c'est des la
majorité de ces gens-là c'est
probablement des années citoyens qui
font leur travail je dirais peut-être
que quelques pommes pourris dans l'eau
comme partout comme partout
[Musique]
la même personne je te jure son discours
là il change comme ça mais c'est
peut-être 2% 5% qui appellent de 9 ans
mais malheureusement c'est c'est des
gens mais c'est ça l'affaire c'est que
si les médias sociaux sont tellement
nourris de choses parfois positives
parfois négatives quand c'est négatif et
c'est toujours principalement ou souvent
la même profession et c'est toujours des
scandales le vidéo est édité d'une
intervention policière ça là franchement
ou les policiers comme exemple un
exemple très simple c'est bien qu'ils
ont des écoutent et inventions
policières pour contrôler quelqu'un qui
t'a qui est en dent qui part dans il
fait un danger autour de lui il faut
l'arrêter égalité armée par mes quelque
chose dangereux puis il y a 4 5
policiers qui tombent sur toi pour te
contrôler à tout le monde veut parler à
bu à plus policiers
si je te prends et je te mets à terre
jamais je pourrais te contrôler
tu vas tellement te dire ça va être
difficile en tout cas très difficile et
malheureusement je risque de te blesser
parce que j'arriverai pas mais si j'ai
un partenaire qui prend un bras une
jambe une autre jambe du coup tu vas
sentir que oups
finalement je suis en train de contrôler
ton corps sécuritément je prends ton
bras mais les menottes tu t'es pas
blessé je me suis pas blessé et
t'abaissé personne autour mais le soir
[Musique]
c'est pas enseigné ça c'est légal mais
le genou c'est l'omoplate il est même
pas juste enseigné exactement c'est
encouragé mettons-nous au ta jambe ton
petit bien sur le mot plate pour
l'aplatir mais pas trop faut qu'il soit
dégagé pour qu'il respire non mais ça
c'est enseigné
4 5 personnes pour contrôler une
personne mais si tu aurais suivi vidéo
pendant 15 secondes tu vois jusqu'à
personne qui se mettent sur une personne
si c'était près de bras ça semble
un reportage de Radio-Canada justement
des policiers qui ont parlé à visage
couvert de justement le fait que tout
est filmé certains policiers
et des moments qui est surtout quand il
y a des questions justement des
minorités pour pas se faire accuser des
racisme quoi que ce soit il est possible
je préfère pas s'en mêler plutôt que
d'intervenir pour éviter que une vidéo
soit pris le devenir de venir une tête
de turc de venir dire espèce de visage
du policier raciste mais je l'ai vu je
l'ai vu et puis elle m'a demandé est-ce
que c'est un phénomène existant oui
existant la démobilisation et le crime à
droite il y en a qui regarde à gauche ça
c'est quelque chose qui nous préoccupe
beaucoup beaucoup parce que quand tu es
rendu là c'est que tu es rendu à te
désengager mais est-ce que est-ce que
juste pour faire une micro parenthèse
sur ça quand on parle de de le crime met
à gauche regardez à droite est-ce que ce
n'est que lié à cette peur-là d'être
pris en vidéo c'est aussi que des fois
c'est juste de pas vouloir se mêler
d'une situation c'est la pression
médiatique ok c'est vraiment la pression
médiatique le
qu'est-ce qui est désolé c'est que vous
voyez un événement
nous les policiers on a quelques
secondes
à créer une magie pour prendre une
décision pour que tout devient et tout à
l'heure j'ai dit le 9 à 1 le service
public s'est rendu un fourre-tout on
nous a fait pour n'importe quoi que
pense deux minutes toi tu es un
spécialiste dans ces émissions que tu
fais et je demande de faire ça et de
faire ça et des autres qui ont même pas
rapport avec ton métier tu vas te
tromper c'est certain ça sans aucun
doute la même chose pour les policiers
on arrive sur des appels madame
Tartempion qui a pris le 91 la puis nous
on arrive là qu'est-ce qu'on fait la
mérité elle est là c'est trop tard un
peu plus reculé et que là tu dis ok mais
moi je suis une police pas psychologue
je peux être travailleur social comment
je vais intervenir là-dedans avec
quelqu'un qui est en crise tu essayes
puis finalement parfois ça va bien
parfois ça dérape mais on te juge
final parce que tu es jugé par des
comités par la suite pendant des années
et toi tu dois être tombé en maladie
parce que tu es plus capable de prendre
la pression média sociaux t'écrase
auprès de ton autiste scandalisé par
tout toute ta réputation est faite ton
épouse ton chante tes enfants à l'école
tout le monde les austratisent plutôt tu
as essayé de faire quelque chose que tu
maîtrisais pas mais 91 ce cours tout le
monde t'as pas de bon sens ça a pas de
bon sens mais c'est vraiment dire à nos
policiers premièrement la formation
continue donc de développer des
formations additionnelles en santé
mentale la formation continue même une
fois
mais il faut que tu sois toujours des
formations adaptées la société change il
y a plein d'émergence des des
problématiques qui émergent mais comment
que le policier peut s'adapter à ça mais
aussi
et je vais faire avec toi tout récemment
j'ai fait une sortie qui a un peu
secoué le milieu de le milieu policier
puis le milieu des citoyens où j'ai dit
ça va ça va devoir arrêter que les
policiers répondent à toute et n'importe
quoi c'est ça faut que ça arrête
il va falloir qu'on parle avec le
ministère de la Santé oui il va falloir
que chez eux qu'il y ait des
intervenants psychosociaux qui eux vont
se appelle là mon mes policiers ils vont
faire la possible on n'est pas des
spécialistes et malheureusement parfois
ça finit mal parfois ça finit mal puis
penses-tu que j'ai un policier une
policière qui veut tirer quelqu'un en
soulevant le matin aujourd'hui c'est le
temps de me taper un noir et de latino
en arabe ou quelqu'un qui tentait ou
quelqu'un qui dira aujourd'hui je vais
tirer si un an soit que ce soit la
minorité
pourquoi faire porter tout ça nos
policiers puis c'est tellement mais
tellement amitié complexe et en même
temps très honorable très très fier
d'être policier mais comment ça se fait
qu'on veut du bashing à ce point là sur
ce métier là qui pourtant là pour
souvent aider aussi mais malheureusement
c'est pas ça qui ressort mais je sais
pas j'ai pas la recette de tout mais
meilleure formation continue mais aussi
faire porter le fardeau à tout le monde
pas juste policier puis aussi éducation
de la population qui appelle le 91 oh
mon doux si tu savais comment les appels
ne fait un sont racisées
et il y a quatre cinq mois qui se
battent en arrière va venir c'est des
gangs de rue
tu arrives en train de jouer OK
jamais vous aurez appelé oh émission
fatigants là ça sent pas bon cette
histoire là
voyons madame il y a plein plein qui
sont du profil donc vous vous arrivez
sur les lieux plus vous avez aussi un
peu là des policiers qui arrivent qui
interviennent
à des jeunes Dominique et ça c'est une
histoire vraie les policiers sont
arrivés quand on a dit gang du riz se
battent en arrière ça ça veut dire
peut-être couteau tu arrives avec des
fêtes
avec trois quatre véhicules puis tu
arrives
les policiers il y en avait un qui était
corrects encore plus avancées
puis là il appelle la centrale arrêter
d'envoyer des renforts arrêtez de suite
on est en train de crier un événement
les jeunes voient les policiers arriver
eux prennent leur bateau là mais oui
donc elle c'est leur confirme le racisme
tel politique
faut que je te montre qu'est-ce que j'ai
à l'écran de l'appel que j'ai reçu sur
l'ordinateur et lui cache l'endroit de
la peine parce qu'il veut pas avoir des
représailles il dirait un appel
[Musique]
on est appelé nous on est appelé on
choisit pas que soit noir ou soit en
train de jouer à qui nous dit vous
arrivez à tellement de reprises des
appels racisés c'est
racisé intergénérationnel
c'est fou des personnes aînées les
personnes jeunes la musique pas de
musique dans les mêmes blocs c'est fou
les appellent
au niveau du genre
orientation sexuelle
itinérance
on est rendu vraiment un four tout
puis sur la question du profilage racial
il y avait eu je pense ça a été une
étude qui était sorti le qui montrait
que c'était un fait comment est-ce que
on peut aller à ça c'est quoi la le
profil selon toi ça vient de où est-ce
que c'est fondamentalement
dans le système mais je pense je pense
que j'ai reconnu que le il y avait du
racisme systémique
et de discrimination systémique mais les
gens tout de suite on l'a
malheureusement habitude de parler de
systématique c'est comme si je disais
que chaque policier n'est pas du tout
pas du tout j'ai des policiers racistes
et comme la société RS6 j'en ai un peu
partout mais j'avais pas tant que ça par
contre que le système soit raciste et
qui a des discriminations systémique ça
absolument il y a personne qui va me
faire dire le contraire
parce que tu le toi-même vécu
j'ai les fait vivre j'ai fait du profil
et chef de police dans les années 90 je
travaillais comme responsable des gang
de rue au niveau de certains clans de
gang de rue puis j'ai fait du profilage
racial ce qui est particulier c'est sûr
c'est sournois c'est subtil c'est
souvent souvent très inconscient donc
dans les années 90 j'en ai fait à des
Noirs qui circulent derrière eux puis
avec la musique M&M's puis deux trois
dents en or genre ça c'est du gang de
rue
je prends une c'est certain du coup le
gars
de Noël tu l'as attiré par tout ce que
tu vois jouer et moi je vais rien il
avait raison c'était le véhicule on a
encore qui passait à côté avec deux
blancs québécois cinquantaine d'années
qui eux transportaient 15 kilos de
j'ai jamais réalisé que c'était donc
j'avais à la peste pêche au lieu d'aller
à la chasse et là j'ai compris je dis
fade profilage racial premièrement c'est
pas productible
deuxièmement c'est iniquitable c'est
inégal
mais après le 11 septembre 2001 moi je
suis originaire
et là j'ai dit ok mais c'est pas le
douanier au costum qui me le faisait
vivre à chaque fois c'est pas lui ils
ont volé là j'ai voulu au système qui
disait ni en Côte d'Ivoire d'origine
libanaise seule tu mets ça de côté puis
tu sais quoi
le pire c'est que je leur disais je suis
policier là
c'est prendre conscience et ta question
est bonne parce que est-ce qu'on a tous
des préjugés de stéréotypes en nous oui
très surpris tout le monde mais oui
la différence que moi comme on uniforme
je peux pas me le permettre que ça
transmette sur le terrain dans mon salon
que je décide d'avoir une certaine
préjugés ça t'appartient mais dès que tu
portes uniforme tu ne peux pas donc
comment faire travailler la psychique du
conscient inconscient et dans les
entraînants formation continue il y a
des formations très très intéressantes
là dessus où tu te dénotes et te
dépersonnalise l'approche puis exemple
je donne un exemple je sais pas quel
véhicule vous avez vous avez peut-être
22 25 ans
que Dominique il a une Porsche 911 Turbo
et il a 22 ans puis circule avec ça sur
celle-là
un petit peu plus qu'une Porsche
monsieur madame tout le monde à la
maison qui te voit sac avec la Porsche à
22 ans ça se peut tu qu'ils vont se dire
qu'est-ce qui clash avec ça mais c'est
exactement ça du profilage
et c'est exactement ce que mes policiers
monsieur maintenant dans la maison ils
peuvent décider mais toi en uniforme tu
as intérêt à avoir beaucoup plus que ça
parce que sinon ce gars là
ici c'est son père qui l'a prêté la
Porsche alors à chaque jour il va se
faire interpeller puis après ça il va se
faire il va haïr la police
c'est là qu'on se dit fais attention
s'il n'a rien fait si c'est pas le
comportement
par exemple
le 11 septembre
les douanes américaines avaient 53
indicateurs qui ont été terroristes
leurs fruits positif était de 15%, 85 %
font négatif
et un groupe spécial sur les terroristes
je dirais pas quel nom un groupe spécial
est venu entraîner des costumes
américains les doigts américaines
voici 4 critères comportementales et je
vais pas te les donner mais quatre
critères pour te comportementales et
regarde ça et regarde il faut ils sont
passés à 84 % de fruits positifs juste
sur un comportement et jamais sur le
look ah ouais juste le comportement
quatre critères sur 53
regarde le comportemental si tu as un
Woody
et que le Audi en arrière il est rond il
aurait dit il peint mais c'est rond
dans un bar de femme
le bas parfois il déborde la quand tu
vois un gars par chèque
quand tu vois ça je m'en fous de quelle
couleur idée
on va vérifier va vérifier va voir
qu'est-ce qu'il y en a même chose pour
les le même Rudy mais les pointus il y a
quelque chose il est pas louche regarde
observe ça démarre est-ce qu'il y a une
âme entre les gens est-ce que sa jambe
débordent à chaque fois il y a plein de
techniques de comportement faut que tu
observes avant la couleur avant le
rameur
il y a certains qui suggèrent de
complètement arrêter les les
interventions aléatoires
interpellation puis vous vous opposez à
ça
des chercheurs j'étais d'accord sur tout
j'ai toute reconnue et ils ont huit
recommandations et oui je vais tout les
suivre
l'enjeu du moratoire je donne un exemple
c'est comme si on me disait Fadi on fait
une étude
sur ta ceinture tu as pu spray tu es un
bâton de sport télescopique
qu'on fait c'est sur le bâton
télescopique a pris vérification on voit
que ton bâton télescopique c'est pas une
molécule
mais ça c'est un outil
à la racine du problème
qu'est-ce que tu fais que tu fais que
des œufs qu'est-ce que tu fais que le
reste si tu me touche à mon bâton je
vais toujours autre chose alors moi ce
que je dis au moratoire j'ai dit c'est
un geste symbolique peut-être important
et je l'ai mentionné que je veux
décevoir les groupes communautaires je
vais décevoir le milieu racisé comme le
noir les autochtones puis les Arabes
mais je veux pas être symbolique je veux
pas être un chef symbolique dans le
paraître je veux vraiment travailler sur
la racine du problème et enlever le plus
possible parce que tu enlèves le
moratoire donne un exemple tu mets le
moratoire en nouvelle école c'est ce que
vous faites ça peut fonctionner ça fait
trois ans
à Toronto ils ont encore plus encadré
les interpellations ça peut
nécessairement fonctionner les policiers
ne font plus d'interpellation il faut
autre chose
alors je me dis il y a personne qui veut
toujours la racine et tout ça structure
et tous aux outils mais ils vont jamais
toucher à la culture moi c'est la
culture changer la culture changer la
culture changer la culture ça prend des
années
et je passe à effet de plaisir le
moratoire mais je suis convaincu que ça
n'aurait pas servi à grand chose
il a suivi la recommandation puis au
contraire maintenant je me fais haïr de
ne pas avoir suivi le moratoire mais je
suis foncièrement que c'est pas la
solution c'est pour ça je parlais de la
j'aurais gagné en popularité dans les
dans les milieux communautaires
probablement j'aurais pas gagné dans la
popularité à l'interne mais ça rien à
voir avec la tête quelqu'un a écrit
récemment que il voulait pas déplaire à
son gênant dès que j'ai vu le Morato je
sais quoi ça c'est symbolique
pire que ça j'ai un problème
présentement dans le village gay
vraiment vraiment électrique là il y a
la vente de stupéfiants il y a beaucoup
d'alcool il y a des itinéraires
puis on me dit je suis allé marcher avec
ma mère récemment
le match des commerçants on est bien
content de vous policiers mais ils
peuvent tu parler aux gens ça c'est
l'interpellation
comment on peut vous aider on vous voit
ici faire des va-et-vient et quelqu'un
qui est avec vous de temps en temps mais
il rentre il sort votre quoi il sait
exactement on veut comprendre mais seul
on aimerait vous votre nom ça va
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans le coin
ça c'est de l'interpellation mais si je
le moratoire je peux plus le faire mais
en même temps la population qui me dit
Monsieur la guerre faites quelque chose
rencontrer allez voir puis faites en
sorte que les choses bougent tu
comprends comment c'est et puis pire on
va rajouter notre couche on a des
fusillades à Montréal malheureusement
dans une période maintenant grâce à Dieu
on est à -30% mais disons que je mets le
moratoire hier et dans deux semaines ça
tire à Montréal pour toute sorte qu'il y
a rien à voir avec l'interprétation rien
à voir avec moratoire tu sais qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont dire médiatiquement ah
depuis que le moratoire a été respecté
ça tire la violence alors ramener
enlever le moratoire c'est un piège
c'est un catcheur et tout je peux pas
aller là
il me semble que les interpellations
le problème et la sur représentation des
minorités dans les interpellations parce
qu'il y a une interpellation en tant que
telle moi je voudrais évidemment quand
on en parle on en parlait justement
suite à l'incident on a parlé beaucoup
de de ça puis du racisme systémique des
on parlait avec
12 fois ma vie moi ça m'est arrivé juste
une fois et puis sauf que
l'interpellation en tant que tel
c'est vraiment pas grave si ça t'arrive
pas ah oui de façon délivrée je me
rappelle j'étais dans la voiture de mes
parents qui est une Cadillac je suis
dans le quartier Limoux à une heure de
la nuit par qui est devant chez ma
blonde à attendre que descende le thé
puis là évidemment que je suis super
j'ai genre 18 ans dans une Cadillac à
Limoilou à une heure de la nuit ici avec
là le policier était venu me voir puis
il m'avait dit salut
j'attends ma blonde là tu peux l'envoyer
comme la lumière de sa chambre allumée
ils prennent du temps à changer des fois
[Rires]
elle est blonde on est tout le temps en
train d'attendre après nos blondes plus
les comme toi mais effectivement
j'ai l'impression que des
interprétations comme ça le problème est
vraiment dans toujours représentation de
certains groupes ici c'est peut-être là
il est là le problème puis je donnais je
vais donner un exemple concret un moment
donné dans les années 2000 début 2000 la
Ville de Montréal avait décrété
tolérance zéro sur des incivilités
qu'est-ce que vous les avez tolérance
zéro incivilité dans les parcs donc tout
ce qui est saleté tout ce qui mais les
magots à terre mal utilisé les bandes et
des papas
mais il demande la police d'appliquer
des règlements
la police descend dans les parcs les
endroits publics pour appliquer
directement
si tu habites à westmartre mon royaume
Saint Michel ou des clientèle aussi en
appartement et l'endroit de ceux qui
peuvent respirer dans le parc donc qui
tu côtoies tout le temps c'est la même
clientèle la fois les racisé parfois
elle est artiste dans le parc laurier
mais ces gens-là voyons les policiers
tout le temps à venir appliquer des
règlements dans les parcs des
incivilités tolérance zéro
mais c'est sûr je comprends c'est ce que
les plus que la personne qui habite à
westmar puis c'est là que je dis la
ville faisant attention de règlement
municipaux parce qu'on crée nous-même la
propre discrimination je comprends si
vous m'envoyez dans les parcs pour aller
faire en sorte que le parc soit toujours
clean mais je vais faire affaire avec
toujours le même population
malheureusement heureusement peu importe
c'est parce que devrait se menthe puis
c'est pas à ceux de quartier puis c'est
plutôt beaucoup plus telle est un
quartier c'est pour ça que mon ami
le niveau de
[Musique]
tolérance envers la police elle est très
très fine parce que les policiers
travaillent toujours généralement dans
les mêmes coins où ils sont demandés de
poser ça c'est un exemple mais ça ne
justifie aucunement
aucunement que nous policiers
interpellent plus souvent des noirs des
Arabes des autochtones et c'est
là-dessus que quand je te parle exemple
dans immersion ils vont aller vivre des
autochtones ils vont aller côtoyer c'est
que moi ma troisième soirée des
immersion je suis allé dans un milieu
autochtone de refus ils m'ont refusé la
place
de police sur nous tu rentres pas ici
je me suis assis 1h30 avec lui à terre
pour lui demander à s'il te plaît
laisse-moi je veux vivre je suis chef
six mois je peux comprendre je vais
essayer de transmettre le message à ma
gang non
puis à la fin je me suis levé j'ai rien
dit quand je vais te respecter je vais
aller chez moi j'avais hâte de dormir
chez moi je vais aller chez moi dormir
tranquille puis il vient me voir une
seule nuit mais promets-moi que tu as
mis du changement dans ta culture
il faut qu'on travaille donc j'ai pas
d'excuse par rapport à aux résultats
c'est j'ai pas d'excuse pour dire j'ai
des raisons pour qu'on en quitter plus
non faut faire preuve de foi dire voilà
oui ça arrive maintenant comme encore eu
en y remédie c'est quoi les
c'est quoi les plus grands défiles qui
est qui attendent l'aspvm puis pour
Montréal mettant en 2023
il y a un mot qui arrête pas de revenir
maintenant dans ma tête là c'est un
service de police proactif prédictible
qui participent les émergences des
problématiques si on reste à une police
réponse aux appels un appel un char un
appel un chat
on peut déjà c'est
75780 millions sociétés en popul
continuer comme ça il faut trouver des
manières d'être là avant les événements
et avant les crises donc exemple les
appels de santé mentale comment des
partenaires de 1900 peuvent aller
exemple
ça fait 10 fois qu'il appelle le 91 par
mois mais on sait qu'il appelle le faim
quelque part du milieu de la santé mais
la balise vous allez le voir avant qu'il
appelle pour les prochaines années quand
il faut pour toutes ça c'est une manière
ça c'est un des plus grands notifie
c'est tout l'aspect des médias sociaux
mais aussi de la cybercriminalité là tu
vois on est ensemble on est en train de
marcher ensemble dans la rue puis le
policier qui travaille avec un visuel de
crime et de comportement criminels il va
regarder
prête à faire un esprit de village
ensemble et la violence armée la
violence armée qui est rendue tellement
banalisée c'est tellement fou comment il
y a des jeunes armes soit pour attaquer
soit se pose pour se protéger puis là
quand je parle déjà je te parle pas de
25 ans là 16 ans 17 ans ils s'arment
pour se protéger ou dans une partie une
amie à moi sa fille à 15 ans
une école privée là
le jeune dieu
regarde école privée coûte plusieurs
milliers de dollars par année qui
capotaient
pas un noir en arabe c'est un blanc là
voyons donc il a pas un chef de gang là
encore une fois on dirait que c'est
comme une espèce de réalité qu'on
importe
cette culture là des armes à feu des des
gangs de rue vraiment armés j'ai pas le
souvenir que ça existait tant que ça
ici avant maintenant on dirait que
à ce moment mais dans les années 70
Montréal était de Carrefour des hold-up
de banque ok vraiment c'était des
fusillades des fusillades des fusillés
des fusillades c'est la le carrefour des
vols vols qualifiés dans les banques et
bon et une période de la mafia des gangs
plus québécoises italienne irlandaises
et tout
plus tard on a vécu dans les années 90
l'amour plus gagne de rue puis des
motards et la mafia
[Musique]
la revente il faut que tu l'as mis dans
le dans au port dans la conteneur et ça
va dans un autre pays la revente se fait
entre 75 et 80 000 US
ça c'est du 700 800%
si tu fais pony
pas grand-chose
[Musique]
la compétition donc on va s'armer pour
se protéger lorsqu'on voit le véhicule
et là c'est comment
je te parle de
préditivités émergences est-ce que
j'aurais pu anticiper la PC peut-être
crypto monnaie ce que j'aurais pu penser
que disons ils vont vouloir la frauder
merde j'ai manqué j'ai réagi donc il
faut être capable d'essayer d'être avant
les tendances très très important parce
que non on va être une police réactive
on peut plus être réactif dans les
années 2023
on doit te laisser partir
un mot pour la fin du parlais de message
tantôt que tu voulais venir que tu
voulais être transporté dans les médias
est-ce qu'il y a des messages que tu as
pas partagé
Éboué on a parlé de plusieurs messages
mais moi je te dirai j'aime les points
que Dominique a amené aussi plutôt aussi
sur
Mélenchon pas les différentes la
profession policière de différents pays
vous avez des policiers des policiers
qui ont une vocation tellement de
vouloir aider protéger c'est fou moi je
suis extrêmement fier du travail de mes
policiers et de mes policiers ou SPVM
même au Québec j'ai vécu Longueuil
très très touchant moi ce que j'invite
on va faire quelque chose pourquoi vous
venez pas patrouille avec nous
une soirée
Cobra ça s'appelle un cobra chez nous
viens vivre une soirée je suis une
soirée 8h de temps sur le véhicule
police et tu vas voir ce que je te parle
ça te mental les appels racisés la
détresse humaine de faire envoyer de la
merde sur toi lancer sur toi vie avec ça
tu pues toute la soirée après c'était un
vrai homme
policière là c'est tellement difficile
ce métier là puis qui s'engage encore je
suis impressionnant le message que
j'aimerais envoyer c'est c'est plus
avant de juger trop rapidement
prenez le temps de une retenue
émotionnellement puis posez-vous la
question si tu fasciste qu'est-ce qu'il
fait c'est pas évident
venez patrouille je vous invite vraiment
ça me ferait plaisir j'aimerais beaucoup
tu acceptes surtout là les dualités
merci beaucoup je suis très content